salut romain ça va oui toi ton tatouages
or c'est quand même dingue en 2018 on
n'est toujours pas trouvé un truc qui
marche en boîte on a peut-être trouvé un
truc mais bon quoi bâtons jetés explique
t il à un peu plus d'un an maintenant je
me suis fait tatouer et j'en ai fait une
vidéo je suis presque sûr que vous en
souvenez moi en tout cas je m'en
souviens bien
dans cette vidéo je n'ai des
explications sur le tatouage et
notamment sur la raison pour laquelle
lancre reste en place sous la peau et je
disais ça en plus les cellules qui sont
chargés de faire le ménage dans le béarn
qu'on appelle des maquereautage elle
n'arrive pas évacuer les pigments de
lancre parce qu'ils sont trop fade pour
elle du coup l'anc
elle reste sur place et finit par être
absorbé par d'autres cellules qu'on
appelle des fibroblastes et qui garde la
couleur sur place sans bouger à l'époque
c'était l'explication la plus
communément admise mais il ya une
découverte toute récente qui est venu
changer la donne une équipe de
chercheurs de l'inserm du cnrs et de
l'université d'aix marseille s'est
penché sur la question et leurs
résultats ont été publiés dans le
journal of experimental medicine
l'anglais les médias du monde entier en
ont parlé
et comme je l'aï dit dans une vidéo
précédente vous avez été très très très
très nombreuses et très très nombreux à
m'envoyer plein d'articles possible j'ai
contacté un des chercheurs en question
qui s'appelle bernard malissen il m'a
tout bien expliqué et moi je vais vous
raconter donc jusqu'ici on pensait que
les pigments injecté sous la peau était
trop gros pour être évacués par les
macrophages qu'ils sont censés faire le
ménage et que du coup ils étaient fixés
dans les fibroblastes qui sont des
cellules de notre berne
mais ce que suggère la découverte des
chercheurs c'est qu'en réalité ce qui se
passe c'est que les macrophages
il absorbe quand même lancre sans
pouvoir l'évacuer et qu'après ils
restent sur place avec le guide plein de
pigments donc en fait c'est eux les
macrophages qui garde la couleur en
place et pas les fibroblastes est encore
pire ils ont découvert que les
macrophages
bon ils sont pas immortels quand il y en
a un qui meurt relâche langues et y en a
un autre qui arrive
kir et absorbe lancre et qui restent sur
place donc c'est sans fin attends ça
veut dire que le macrophage il mange ce
que son pote mort viens de vomir
bon c'est peut-être pas les mêmes
conventions sociales chez les
macrophages on va pas les juger en plus
de nous aider à comprendre comment
langue des tatouages reste en place ces
découvertes et pourrait aussi avoir des
applications sur le détatouage et là
vous comprenez qu'en plus d'éveiller la
curiosité d'un point de vue théorique
ça m'intéresse aussi d'un point de vue
plus pratique et plus personnel en gros
tout ça ça remet en cause la théorie
selon laquelle c'est les macrophages qui
évacue les fragments d'encre une fois
qu'elle a été explosée par le laser en
vérité a priori il garde aussi en place
les petites particules explosé qu'ils
arrivent à rbo fait quand j'en ai
discuté avec bernard mali cnj m'a
expliqué que c'était possible qu'en fait
les fragments d'encre il soit captée par
d'autres cellules du système immunitaire
est évacuée par le réseau lymphatique
qui s'occupe aussi des bactéries et des
virus
du coup l'idée pour leur permettre de
bosser tranquillement ce serait
d'inactiver temporairement les
macrophages sur la zone du tatouage pour
éviter leur bouffe directement lancre
quand elle a été exposée par le laser
ok mais comment on fait ça les
chercheurs pensent qu'ils pourraient
produire des anticorps qu'on appelle des
anticorps monoclonaux et qui sont
capables de reconnaître les molécules
qui se trouve sur les macrophages et
d'aller se fixer dessus sur ces
anticorps y ferait une toxine capable
d'inactiver les macrophages pour une
durée limitée
et alors comment est-ce qu'on enverrait
tout ça précisément au contact de
langres valider ce serait d'appliquer le
produit avec les anticorps sur la peau
au niveau du tatouage et de le faire
pénétrer dans le verbe avec un laser
alors pas le même laser que pour le
détatouage ça serait un laser qui est
utilisé en cosmétique est capable de
faire des micro trous dans la peau ce
qui permettrait aux anticorps de
pénétrer alors ça a l'air d'être de la
science fiction comme ça mais en vrai
c'est une technique est déjà expérimenté
pour faire des vaccins sans injection
par exemple une fois que les anticorps
se sont fixés sur les macrophages et que
la toxine leur à fermer leur clapet il
reste plus qu'à passer un coup de laser
là dessus pour exploser l'an
le laser de détatouage est celui qu'on
connaît bien
surtout mois après il reste plus qu'à
laisser faire le système lymphatique qui
doit évacuer tout ça alors je sais vous
allez me dire oui mais tout ça c'est du
conditionnel
bah oui parce que même si les chercheurs
sont très confiant sur les chances de
réussite de la technique elle n'a pas
été testé alors vous pensez bien moi mon
sang n'a fait qu'un tour je me suis dit
je vais me proposer comme sujets humains
pour l'expérimentation
sauf que sauf que ce genre
d'expérimentations ça prend du temps ça
coûte de l'argent et qu'en l'occurrence
les chercheurs y z'ont ni l'un ni
l'autre parce que c'était pas du tout ce
qui était prévu au programme au départ
du coup ça ira pas plus loin soit pas de
leur côté ont alors peut-être qu'un jour
il ya quelqu'un qui mettra de l'argent
pour financer sa et mettre au point une
méthode révolutionnaire de détatouage
mais pour le moment à deux doigts
d'ouvrir un nul mois du combat je vais
devoir trouver une autre solution pour
mon petit cas personnel alors en vrai
j'ai déjà trouvé
je vous en reparler très bien on voit la
dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo
d'ici là mettez vous bien et surtout pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]